لذلك قالت وعمليه الجنوب الاوكرانيه الى
روسيا تستعد لهجوم صاروخي واسع النطاق على
جنوب اوكرانيا واضفت ان قوتها ترصد نشاطا
ملحوظا لطائره الاستطلاع الروسيه وان
دفاعاتها اسقطت خلال اليومين الماضيين
عددا من تلك الطائرات لاسيما في منطقه
البحر الاسود
وقالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه شلت غارات جويه على مقاطعات عده
خصوصا في مقاطعه خرسون جنوب البلاد واضافت
ان القوات الروسيه وصلت قصفها المدفعيه
على قرى وبلده تقع على خط التماس في خرسون
ومقاطعه زاكولوجيا واشارت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه الى ان خطر تنفيذ هجمات
الروسيه واسعه النطاق على المرافق المدنيه
لا يزال مرتفعا في عموم البلاد كما اكدت
الهيئه ان قواتها نفذت سلسله غاره على
مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
افاد عمده
فيتالي بتجدد القصف المدفعيه الروسيه على
تجمعات المياه الساحليه في منطقه اوتشاكوف
وكوستروف واضاف ان عموما المقاطعه
الجنوبيه يعاني قطاعا في خدمه الماء منذ
ثلاثه ايام بسبب الضربات الروسيه الى جانب
قطاعات متكرره في الكهرباء